vous dire ça fait dix ans que chargé
matin la dernière bonjour division où
trouver 457 niches fiscales il n'y a
rien sur le pouvoir d'achat rien sur les
retraites on appris des premières
mesures
j'entends parfois que cdcc des miettes
bah moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça une
rencontre sans intermédiaire sans filtre
ou chacune des voix et portait de
manière égale à saint désert se tenait
ce samedi un jeu de questions réponses
entre l'état et ses citoyens
les cons stanislas grigny et une
centaine de gilets jaunes de
saône-et-loire dialogue l'exercice
s'avère périlleux on sent qu il ya
beaucoup de colère quand on commence à
la discussion mais que dès qu'on arrive
à nouer le dialogue on arrive à échanger
des vraies informations et c'est comme
ça que ça doit se passer c'est à ça que
ça doit servir ce moment là je suis
travailleur handicapé
j'ai travaillé toute ma vie j'ai été
licenciée en invalidité deuxième
catégorie alors déjà je me retrouve avec
50 pour ça mon salaire et j'ai pas eu
droit au chômage
pourquoi on essaye de trouver des
solutions un pour vous touchez plus et 2
pour s'asseoir un peu plus simple mais
après une demi heure de débats intenses
les impressions de l'audience reste
mitigé ils sont pas venus à notre
rencontre on est venu à la leur ils
n'ont pas le choix ils disent qu'ils
viennent du disque dégoût parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas le choix c'est bien quand
même qu'ils se déranger de l'ambiance
tranche avec le cadre plus confortable
des voeux à la section de saône et loire
de la république en marche présenté
quelques minutes plus tôt dans la salle
municipale
à l'extérieur on se réchauffe comme on
peut en attendant les élus locaux député
de la 3e circonscription de saône et
loire
rémy rebeyrotte n'a lui pas voulu sortir
en désaccord avec la forme on est sur un
aéropage d'extrémistes qui essaye de se
déstabiliser la république
alors moi je veux bien recevoir des gens
dans des formes républicaine mais je ne
le ferais certainement pas sur le champ
de foire
les députés nous méprisent pourquoi on
est là aujourd'hui c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça même les députés
comment voulez-vous que à président nous
écoute si ses sbires ils nous écoutent
pas en ce jour d'actes 10 saint-désert
aura été un épisode de plus dans la
crise de la représentation
caractéristiques du mouvement
[Musique]